we're drafting the most intriguing
available free agents Peter King you get
the first pick of all of the players
left on the board in free agency we're
gonna select the ones we find the most
intriguing who do you have Jameis
Winston is number one for me because I
think that if I was a coach and felt
like felt that I could have sort of the
tough love of Jameis wins you know if I
could have tough love working with
Jameis Winston I'd really want to give
that a shot he's got too great a
downfield arm and he's been too
productive a player except for his
decision-making and again that's a huge
except for but I'm fascinated I would
just love to get him on my team and I
would love it look you listen to Bruce
Arians this week did you hear in one of
his interviews that he is called to
coaches and I don't know who they are
I really don't know who they are but who
knows maybe they were Doug Marrone and
Mike Tomlin although I doubt it was Mike
Tomlin but but maybe they were two
coaches with a need for a quarterback
right now and I am fascinated by the
potential long-term of this guy because
he's been so productive and he's still
so young
hey if I was Aryans I'd be doing the
same thing I'd be pushing Jameis Winston
on any coach outside of the division
because if the Saints ultimately decide
they want another Teddy Bridgewater type
veteran back up Winston makes the most
sense get him out of my division I don't
want to have to face him I think last
year the Bucks got the Bucks got
shredded by ten by Teddy Bridgewater I'm
sure that's one of the reasons why he
was on their wish list Teddy Bridgewater
had a great game against Tampa Bay last
year when he was filling in for Drew
Brees alright mine is Cam Newton because
of Cam Newton's healthy he's a top-ten
quarterback he's a 2015 NFL MVP he's
making a late arrival on to the free
agent market and we recognize it's going
to take some time before a team can do a
proper physical they're not gonna have
some neutral outside doctor take a look
at Cam Newton because he's got the foot
issue he's got a past ankle problem he's
got the shoulder injury Peter that last
year caused him to change his throwing
motion so I would want to be able to
complete
and totally poke and prod Cam Newton to
make sure he's healthy but my goodness
if he's healthy he is intriguing he's
one of the best quarterbacks you can get
and he's going to be motivated we had
that workout video earlier he said they
gave up on me in reference to the
Panthers he's gonna be driven to have an
incredible second act of his career he
still isn't 31 yet I mean we got Tom
Brady and Drew Brees playing into their
40s and I don't believe that Cam Newton
will play into his 40s he may not play
past 35 but that's still four or five
more good seasons so I am very intrigued
by what Cam Newton can do once he gets
not a Carolina Panthers conveniently
passed physical but a physical that he
passed with a team that has fully and
completely examined whether or not he's
truly ready for the physical demands of
playing in the NFL yeah I'll go with my
second pick now Mike we've we've
probably exhausted the Cam Newton ID as
my second pick is gonna be a surprise
pick normally I might say give me
Jadeveon Clowney but I don't want to pay
Jadeveon Clowney 20 or 21 million
dollars I just don't feel that he's that
he's an intriguing player but I don't
believe I'd make him a rich intriguing
player I'd want him for 15 or 16 that
could take a couple of months my second
pick is gonna be Prince Amukamara and
look this is a game right now that
relies on getting as many good corners
as you can okay two years ago Pro
Football Focus had Prince Amukamara as
the seventh best cornerback in football
slipped a little bit last year but still
the great thing about Prince Amukamara
he's he's going to not be a shutdown
corner he's going to be a competitive
feisty corner you're not gonna be
completing 70% in his area you're gonna
be getting a guy who's an above average
NFL corner in a value contract I first
be I know he was a first-round pick of
the Giants but he first became well
known in the NFL circles do you remember
how and why Peter do you remember how we
first really became aware of Prince
Amukamara when jpp threw him into the
cold tub remember that video from
several years ago
read him in and throw him into the cold
tub and he had a hard time with the
Giants early on just the whole hazing
and they just pre Richie incognito
Jonathan Martin days
I think the Giants players gave him a
hard time for whatever reason but he's
still going strong in the NFL that is an
intriguing pic and you have left you
Davian clowning on the board for me I
feel guilty taking to Damion cloudy I
don't care how much money he wants the
question for this draft is how
intriguing are they and he is intriguing
because of his potential to wreck an
offensive game plan if he's healthy
but just like Cam Newton I need to know
that he's healthy and maybe if he
languishes long enough on the market I
can steal him for one year with an
incentive heavy deal where I don't have
to pay him unless he plays and unless he
performs and then he's set up for his
big payday next year if he can make it
through the 2020 season healthy so for
me it's no question I still have images
seared into my brain of how well he
played that Monday night in San
Francisco against the 49ers that was the
night the sports hernia started to flare
up and affected him the rest of the year
but he was incredible on that Monday
night game if you can get that guy for
just a handful of games in the season
that may be the difference between
playoffs and no playoffs I think it's a
great pick I just you know I don't want
to pay him twenty 1 million bucks and no
matter how intriguing he is he's not
signing for in the mid-teens right now
so you know I guess it's semantics my
third pick is going to be Everson
Griffin of the Minnesota Vikings I mean
to me this guy has been a steady Eddy
pass rusher for the last eight years or
however many years it's been he's one of
the most dangerous pass rushers in
football so his last year and a half or
so with the Vikings problematic had some
issues off the field as everybody knows
but I think he's got his life in order
right now he is he knows that probably
this is last chance you know to really
make an impact and make real money in
the NFL someone's gonna give him an
incentive Laden contract Mike and be
very very happy by November when he's
third in the NFL in sacks
yeah look that's a great choice and I
almost took him before clowny because
this guy who he has been a sack machine
he's been one of the past best past
rushes of his generation he doesn't get
the credit he deserves and he's a great
leader I think that his departure from
Minnesota hurts that team more than
anyone elses other than maybe Stefon
Diggs but Griffin is a guy that that
defense has rallied around for years and
he will be missed in Minnesota and
somebody's gonna get a very very good
player in a very very good leader in
Everson Griffin all right hey look I may
be fracturing the rules slightly but
this is most intriguing available free
agents and restricted free agents are
still free agents and we talked about
Taysom Hill already how can we not have
Taysom Hill on this list without
question he's in true kids like the dog
you're like you know what you're like
you're like Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth
Warren's dog with what he had his mouth
around a taco or something and they
couldn't get him to let it go so finally
they said well better just let him eat
it you know that's what you are would
Taysom Hill well let me my taco and
leave me alone you agree with me though
especially if he stays in New Orleans
2021 he's gonna be the starting
quarterback and Sean Payton is gonna
turn him into a star yeah well the only
reason I wouldn't include him on this
list is I wouldn't exactly call a free
agent
someone who's gonna require a
first-round draft pick compensation so I
don't know III but technically he's a
free agent so go ahead yeah and and look
I don't think anybody's gonna make that
offer and here's why - first you have to
get him to sign the offer sheet and and
that's what is fascinating to me about
this if he stays and waits a year he
cracks 20 million with the Saints easily
easily cracks 20 million in may have to
use the franchise tag on him next year
to keep him from walking away to another
team but if a team would try to sign him
now they're not offering him 20 million
Peter they're gonna they're gonna offer
him a contract commencer of what he
currently
does so he's gonna blow his chance to be
the saint starting quarterback by taking
a deal that would allow him to continue
to be the jack-of-all-trades for someone
else that to me is the biggest reason
why he's not gonna sign an offer sheet
and leave the Saints no one's gonna put
an offer on the table that he's going to
say oh I have to take this because it's
gonna fulfill my dream of becoming a
franchise quarterback
Mike yeah you're absolutely right if if
you know that there's a 70% chance on on
opening day 2021 you're the quarterback
in the New Orleans Saints and Sean
Payton with Michael Thomas to throw to
an Alvin Kamara to pitch - why in the
world would you choose to go anywhere
else and that to me is one of the really
really big reasons why there's no way in
the world I would I would do that can I
just give you an honorable mention extra
I like I mean to me
Bill Parcells a long time ago he I think
he started this cliche the most
important part of ability is
availability okay to me the most
intriguing person in recent NFL history
who's a free agent right now is a
cornerback by the name of Brandon Carr
and everybody said Brandon Carr he's
just caiis has been on Dallas been on
Baltimore he's never been a big star you
know what Brandon Carr has been
available Brandon Carr is eaten up more
than a thousand snaps think about this
more than a thousand snaps 12 years in a
row okay so in my opinion if I'm looking
for a guy who's even if he's gonna be my
third or fourth corner and I got to pay
him what four million five million this
year I've got the greatest insurance
policy at cornerback and by the way a
mid tier the last couple of years rated
cornerback on Pro Football Focus you
know not the hundred not savior roads
rated you know very low I would take
Brandon Carr and I would love that pic
and I'd love him to come to training
camp to teach my young corners son this
is the way it's done hey I got one for
you
similar vein Peter Logan Ryan is
available at corner there was talk it's
a great point great defensive player of
the year he's missed three games in in
seven NFL seasons and he's got that
winning pedigree from his time with the
New England Patriots and he's the guy
isn't he the guy who who delivered the
dagger to Tom Brady's career in New ALCS
pick six easy he's the last pass yeah he
caught the last pass that last pass from
Brady obviously you know and Mike how
shocked would you be not very if you saw
him sign with the Patriots two years 9
million I mean the one of the reasons
why the Patriots handle free agency in
these weird trades like the Kyle van Noy
ish trade where you're basically trading
you know a fifth round pick for Kyle van
Noy and a seventh or whatever that was
you know that's where the Patriots
really make hay and they turn these guys
into really good players how thankful by
the way must Kyle van Noy be to the New
England Patriots in to Bill Belichick
and to Brian Flores quite honestly for
putting him in position to be a great
player Mike
I voted Kyle van Noy is one of my all
pro linebackers last year and now he
gets a whatever fifty six million dollar
contract with Miami and all I'm saying
is that I want to know on Bill
Belichick's Greece board right now in
his office or right now in his home
office which is where it has to be I
want to know on his Greece board
I want his ten guys right now that he is
waiting for the market to cave in on and
which is in its in the process of doing
and then he's gonna swoop in like a
vulture and he's gonna take the low cost
guys let's say the week of the week
after the draft maybe even a quarterback
who's - an old all-time against the New
England Patriots that would be Cam
Newton and that is the corner square and
PFT bingo that's one of my favorite
favorite stats to point out and I don't
think the Cam Newton fits in New England
but that that's the kind of idea
longer this process goes the financial
demands drop guys become available in
Bella check swoops in and bargain shops
and gets value dollar for dollar better
value than anyone gets in free agent
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports